[Music]
everybody be : 360 live pre-show starts
now
hey guys going on with a conan 360 live
pre-show oh yeah we live baby yeah Chris
red and this is Onan Conan O'Brien in
360 where I'm more pleasing and wearing
reading glasses I like me right yeah you
know happens later in life not to me I'm
gonna live forever I a stigmatism now I
just don't wear the bed is going down
it's much Quinn this is beautiful
there's a balmy breeze yeah if you ever
use the word balmy a lot I use that on
occasion I open up emails with that if
I'm usually asking for some bombs the
paparazzi hounding me go man your
paparazzi like very very expensive
planes they ride in yes yes okay he they
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
to get a picture of me that's really
worth about a dollar really not
cost-effective what's up with Jeremiah
there's a guy Jeremiah one Jeremiah on
the chat he's neglecting his children he
said hey Conan I'm neglecting my
children to watch this I don't know what
I'm watching but I'm watching and I
can't stop so he's got high standards
yeah yeah so his excuse to his life
partner is I duct-taped the children to
a radiator because I had to watch
something that I didn't care that much
about and white really went out of his
way to neglect his kid but it truly did
to us please focus on these live shows
we have a live chat so people in real
time can cyberbully yes as we're
following our dreams oh I never you
can't look at that stuff you can't I do
would love to read you some of the
comments that I've been popping up about
you we have 89 comments oh really and
they're all mostly about how you don't
have a soul behind your eyes oh yeah I
don't have a soul that's true I had it
extracted 1986 it's a surgery that's
like laser
it's the early way the early LASIK also
took your soul yeah also took yourself
that's what we're being paid and we're
being paid in 40% off LASIK eye surgery
I was certificate I will say that
somebody in the chat called me a baby
Hannibal and I was very angry about that
because we are both the same size and I
think he's only a year old how am i baby
I'm not a baby people you know when a
grown man yells I'm not a baby
repeatedly yeah he just reaffirmed and
then when you shake your fist man we got
a good show tonight coming up I gotta
tell you that puppy thing I was
transfixed by the puppy in 360 in
cosplay that blew my mind
I was supposed to be preparing for
tonight's show when I was watching the
puppies instead yeah those puppies are
well trained yes run around in costumes
yes we've got their first taste of
interviewing guests is there any advice
you would have good question Moses yes
sir work yes when you haven't seen their
work yeah let's see that's a good one
I like to feign enthusiasm okay I like
to fake it till I make it right and bake
it I don't even know what that means
that's just stupid it felt like you fake
it and you and you just making good
cakes yeah sounds like to me something
like that which isn't even true all
right no I I really do try to find what
I'm interested in about that person so I
don't have to fake it I really try to
make it real try and find something
about them that you really are
interested in every now and then you got
to ask a question that you don't really
care the answer to you suck it up and
you do it but I would say 80% of the
time try and ask something you're
interested in these are good tips for
you at home too
don't forget to write this down Jim why
you had no keys from yourself yeah I'm
worried about Jeremiah
should we call anybody about Jeremiah do
we know where Jeremiah is okay so he's
in Tucson Arizona oh that's not a good
start
no oh so the children are the the
apartment is probably very hot very hot
oh absolutely y'all kissing me cuz I
will stick out in that city right he's
only four black people there is that
true yeah I don't know do you know them
personally
[Laughter]
there are certain cities where you know
all the black people definitely Utah
Utah I've met Willie in the gorge really
yeah but no well you doing great Utah
Jazz yeah the Utah Jazz yeah of course
but they they don't count do um have you
made any friends with anybody in the
surrounding buildings there's beautiful
downtown San Diego buildings here oh
yeah the Spreckels theater has probably
the best view of all the buildings with
the best view of this guy everybody
that's sitting higher than us waves down
like hey looks dirty
yeah it's a lot of sprite goals did you
know this was a true fact it was the
first theater in America that gave out
concessions they had the idea to give
away popcorn during the shows and that's
where the idea of concession started
that's how old this theater is the
theater is made of 100% and this is true
it's made of asbestos pressed is bad it
was just energy I was telling him energy
juice is not a thing and I was just like
no it is a thing it happens all the time
not reptiles insane we have been just
like roasting this roof a lot but no
joke
in the later shows or spend bees up here
bees it's like the bright colors I'm so
sorry
well this I'm sorry we put you on roof
we we released bees you brought me down
here Jim if you come in real close it's
like a Missy Elliott video from an ID I
can't stand or like a pizza if you
thought I told you that we won't stop
fun fact about that they did stop Wow in
a very alleyway but then they reunion
towards so they yeah there's like
certain angles where if you don't have
the goggles it looks like you've been
released into space yeah that was super
cool it's cool I like this fun vibe all
right guys you're not I'm gonna do I'm
gonna go downstairs ah yeah and I
actually pray I pray before every show
really telogen are you and what is the
best religion I'd love to lock that yeah
it's pretty much been confirmed yeah
okay so piss Cup alien oh I'm not
Episcopalian but you ask anybody yeah
you don't have to really do anything
that's position you don't go to church
you get into any golf club you want in
the world little commitment episcopalian
no commitment and maximum maximum cred
that's awesome yeah you just tell people
you're Episcopalian yeah I'm gonna say
vegetarian they then they glare at me
now
no no just just marry house flirt
Episcopalian and last question how much
money do you specifically make a year
these are all the questions we've been
asking the guests on this show no
problem I make upwards of $200,000 a
year now that isn't that's pretty good
yeah you know for a lot of people but
here's the thing illegally through
various side ventures well I'm talking
about yeah I make hundreds of millions
of dollars see I'm no oxy but I don't
declare that as income because most of
its illegal Zach there's a lot of
laundromats
in my name but I don't pay taxes this is
narcos Conan you here right now yeah
yeah no seriously I have many many
businesses Conoco is an octopus a
nefarious octopus yeah it stretches out
untraceable yeah I officer have anything
you're doing anywhere that's a little
bit sleazy let's say you're buying a
condom at a truck stop and you're
putting a quarter in my favor getting
15% of that condom that's crazy I'm
doing that I can't give to you man yeah
you're doing too well I'm just saying
good thing about me is only need 15% of
a condom these guys are disgusting and
now I have to distance myself from you
okay you know you guys went there and I
can't be part of that I work clean I bow
to all of you yes in the Episcopalian
tradition god speed guys thank you so
much for all your good work you're funny
guys are good they keep watching
Jeremiah we're on to you we're
triangulating your position we're
finding you and we're coming after your
ass we'll see you later everybody I'm
gonna take too long to walk away now and
if you have the VR headset you can watch
Cohen and walk away right now very very
slowly this is how he leaves every night
he slowly backs away hoping for some
applause with that with with a hero
strut they could definitely see you yep
they just keep searching for me call
this fine Conan yep they can still
definitely see you there
it's really brought this to a screeching
halt
yep and that is about 40 more feet of
the room that you have seen right now
you'll see more later of course when
you're watching the actual show we have
some videos of them as well yeah we're
counting down this show again this is
the conan 360 my live show brought to
you by AT&T yes exactly and we have a
bunch of unmanned Kim's right now that
we're gonna check in with and Krista's
gonna be down there later Plainsman
gives us some fans so let's first let's
go to our martyr lobby okay lobby Chris
is gonna be may be down there with some
fans we got some pop figures down there
Jim
yeah now let's go to the artist entrance
because that's where all the fans are
waiting for the famous people to arrive
this area is pandemonium I was down
there on Thursday show the cast of
Kingsman was down there is just
pandemonium people constantly yelling
yeah I still haven't recovered ooh
I did not talk to Halle Berry oh yeah
we'll tell you about that story later
but let's take a look at the stage
that's the stage you see all the people
sitting there yeah you see one guy
bravely wearing orange and white looking
like a pumpkin and that is pretty dope
but also looks like Conan's hair so
that's cool one chance to strong choice
and then back to us back to us on the
roof baby by the time you see us again
it will be dark it'll be dark so this
will definitely look worse as we go
along
yeah but we have some special guests
cast from the people of Earth the tick
and yeah yeah people of Earth great show
another conan code thing from the tick
yeah cool up this here good friend of
mine yeah our properties crater tickets
yeah boy some ticket system people man
I'm gonna make them cry at four which is
gonna be fun to see people cry oh and
put your exclusive like behind the
scenes look at the Dumbledore edition
from Silicon Valley Thomas Middleditch
yeah very funny guys looking forward to
that as well and then and then a tour of
corner himself in his property he's in
like a proper room tour and probably
conceived like behind the desk I think I
should be done that we're gonna see his
younger hair in there so that'd be dope
it's orange err behind the desk yeah
okay let's take a look at that right now
so if you've ever wondered like what is
behind Conan's desk they were nice
enough to give us a tour I think this is
also in 360 so enjoy this is Conan's
desk
hey 360 live here and Conan O'Brien
little special treat I'm going to show
you behind my desk the back of the stage
right here no one has ever seen this
before and this is really incredible
first of all we have plants these are
not real plants these are made of
pressed aluminum and then they're
sprayed with a Dimond mist and then
covered in a green ruby tint so these
cost up to $600,000 each here's my chair
legendary talk-show chair irreplaceable
or you could just go to any Home Depot
and get 60 of these this is the back of
my desk so you see it's worn away right
here from years and years of me grinding
my pelvis up against the edge when I'm
sexually frustrated this is little box
where they keep different things here's
my guitar tuner I play a lot of guitar
at rehearsals so I tune my guitar this
is a device that has actually allows me
to manipulate the moon back there but I
never use it because it got boring after
the second time
I'll deal with a lot of very ill
celebrities so I here's some hand
sanitizer spray that on keep things nice
and good taking tissue right here just
random tissue okay someone tells a real
tearjerker this is a bucket I throw up
in if I really think that the guest has
got nothing and that's about it here's
my mug this is the mug I've been using
here at the show since 1993 my friend
and former writing partner Greg Daniels
made this for me in honor of me getting
the late night show and I've kept it on
my desk ever since
along with Dwight Eisenhower because he
won the war for us
d-day made the big decision alright I've
probably gone on too long
I just thought you should see my desk
probably the thing years gonna remember
the most is this area right here worn
away by my crotch rubbing back and forth
against it after talking to so many very
attractive women and being frustrated
goodbye hey guys you are watching the
conan 360 live show I'm closest Orbitz
Chris red and we are sitting down with
Griffin Newman my man Griffin Newman's
yeah boy look at his cat shows like vine
amazing
Amazon's the tick and those caps just
now yeah Chris we were just talking
about we have known each other for like
five years now cuz you did a really
mediocre stand-up show that I used to
host in a basement it was so is my first
time in the show's mediocre Chris
elevate okay yeah it was very funny
shots fired
that was one it was inspired what was
praying for it I was praying he was
loading the shotgun you want to take a
shot I really want some kind of catfight
just to really use the 360 yeah sure I
wasn't that great all the time so I was
one of those sets where I was like oh I
did great everything's great this is the
Irish pub where Irish people work there
this one Chicago where it was pubs like
kanesha works there and she's got Irish
you know so it was dope to see that
authenticity it was crazy
okay but what's crazy about that is so
you you were just asking me if I was
still doing that show and you're like
that was a great show but I was like it
wasn't it was just good that one night
and I thought oh this must be a guy who
kills it every night cuz you killed it
so hard that night did that show when
Chris Rhodes got it a hundred percent
figured out yeah I bombed for a year
after that show oh wow it was great but
it is crazy to think about you know in
like comedy you like intersect with
these people different levels and it's
like five years ago we were in a dank
basement together and look at us now
we're both on a roof we've made it all
the way great let's talk about you walk
out when I were you a fan of the TIC
like that the cartoon in the comics
before yes yes my mom would not let me
watch the cartoon when it was on yeah
because she was very overprotective
really she thought Rugrats was too
cynical yeah I was not allowed to watch
anything growing up which is why I have
the brain I do now right so people
always will quote like hey you ever seen
home alone and you be like and there was
a lot of cramming once I got to be like
1112 and I could rant stuff on my own
then it was like I gotta watch all this
stuff so I have the same pop-culture
reference points but yeah I will always
want to watch the cartoon it was on I
wasn't allowed to and then when the the
last live-action series the Patrick
Warburton one was on Fox in 2001 my
brother and I were obsessed with that
and would watch it every week but Fox
kinda like wasn't really into that show
and they every week which shift the
timeslot yeah so we'd have to like get
out the TV Guide and figure out where it
was gonna be TV Guide for uh for this
kids watching TV Guide so we and you had
to like look for when times the shows
were on and it was enough abetik --kw
just have to search until you found or
maybe you never found it you just
unhappy for it often times we tell the
show they move that time yes all over
the show and moving it to a different
hour I was really into that and when
that show got canceled prematurely then
I went back into the cartoon and watch
that no I was a big fan for a while
before I got this audition what can you
tell us about your character and the
show just yeah I mean the the tick was
created about 30 years ago by Ben
Adalind who has retained a hand in every
version of it which is pretty cool and
unique that's amazing you know Stanley
doesn't still get to write every version
of spider-man nobody doesn't get to make
very abrupt cameos that bring the movies
to a screeching halt right good actor
they're so organic to the story that's
what I love about this does anyone need
gas no spider-man he kind of I can't
stop marveling at
beautiful weather okay Stan back in the
van we get it your character yes right
so it's created 30 years ago as the sort
of satire of superhero culture and it's
this team of the tick and Arthur and the
tick is kind of a parody of the classic
square-jawed can do superhero but he's
also sort of like a golden retriever he
doesn't really know what he's doing he
doesn't know his own strength he doesn't
know where he came from he's just all
action and Arthur's the opposite Arthur
doesn't have any power he's just out of
shape dude in a moth suit and who can
fly around so anyone could do his job
anyone he doesn't really know how the
suit works he got lucky and he's all
awareness all perception and all anxiety
because of how aware yeah so Arthur's
able to assess the situation tick is
able to take action together they're
each like one whole human being how much
of that of this character is you all
right because you know his whole
audition Griffon which he just came in
and said do you guys hate me yeah I was
trying I was working for seamless I
didn't audition for their show I just
showed up with tacos at a casting office
and they were like this oh right now
have you ever done that though like a
casting director gifts I always feel
like oh yes the other one too I remember
there was one time I was going for
audition I said before I read I just
want to say something to you and she
went oh please don't tell me that you
were born to play this part and I had to
pretend that that was not what I was
about to say and I was like no no I
answer your question though Chris it's a
short walk I would say I'm Griffin so
Arthur there are a lot of parallels so
all the episodes of the tick will be
available August 25th on Amazon what
emotion six are coming out August 25th
the second six will be coming out in
2018 Oh 2018 yeah okay great I brought a
gift for you yes in the spirit of cast
you in anything I hope you know that
oh I'm Mike ashen with so yeah hold on
hold on wait until you see the gift okay
okay I know you hear it Conan you got
you got your Conan Funko pops he's got
the five
I can't compete with that it would be
really cool if I was able to come out
now and give you a Funko pop of myself
that would be like a cool that would be
ideal
move I can't really do that but I can
got them down here you a Funko pop of
the other carrier right out of his pants
to take the I don't play you get a tick
look at that
and these people go crazy for these this
is mine I've said this like I'm a 40
year old people on these internet shut
that out that's so cool thank you so
much well they gifted it to me and then
they said actually yeah we can't get rid
of these things at a wedding and then
saved it for another wedding sure if I
wanted to keep the wedding gift again
thank you to Griffin Newman thank you so
much for our tic and West Coast Customs
build him a superhero car to match this
suit and we're gonna go behind the
scenes of that video right now
Newman let's go in close while we
transition hey Conan here is my good
friend Ryan of course y'all know him
from West Coast custom and he's showing
me around we're gonna shoot a remote for
Comic Con where this gentleman's team
build me an amazing superhero ride we're
gonna take it to the streets of San
Diego love it and I'm gonna solve crimes
with it in San Diego yeah there's a lot
of crime there that's a lot of crime a
lot of crime in San Diego I can't thank
you enough thank you
we're gonna do this we're gonna make
history automotive history automotive
history at comic-con
busting bad guys I mean we can't really
ask for anything you could actually just
a who's how the business works sorry I'm
gonna go this way you go by
great excellent perfect thanks
appearance release sugars I brought you
guys a little thing here Ryan I left you
a little note here in your book it's
right here I think but also I think the
part that you would like to be the
beginning part like why do you want to
keep this - when I got examined I wax
romantic about the 92 Ford Taurus and
you know it's yeah it's pretty fun
it is the SHL the wolf until we can
build on and we can like show like some
old footage of like the commercial of
that car it was funny I never did ads
for the sh o they really kept it on the
down low and I remember just hearing
about it because I loved the idea of
driving a square car that had a cool
engine in it I don't know I always liked
that that idea was appealed to me so the
idea of having a completely pedestrian
Ford Taurus green Ford Taurus that
looked like you know an orthodontist
might have it and I thought okay I love
that and it's had this Yamaha engine
that they put in it it had like 36 valve
you know that it was a very intense
stick shift it's a Ford Taurus with the
stick shifts oh really yeah so they were
and that's called that's why they call
it SH oh yeah but I never saw any
advertising for it anywhere because and
I don't know why I didn't mean but then
I would meet Ford guys and I'd be like
oh Sh oh okay that's cool like it was
the sort of this underground yeah a
secret society of the secret society of
hello guys we've made it mercury and
made a little strange okay funny right
you know I'll make that happen
let me show ya that would be really fun
to be a cool living full episode yeah
I'd almost do like a throwback to it
Yeah right I could take you back to
where I was in life in 92 where was that
I was writing at The Simpsons
I got it in 91 that it was the 92 my my
brother Neil could tell us where we got
we got a mozzie Ford in Massachusetts
and then I didn't know how to drive a
stick when he bought it for me so he
took me to the star market parking lot
we've taught me how to died stick I
bought the car without doing
but I just knew I wanted this car and
that's an awesome story so they just
added they're ready free in the doom
buggy yeah they're just gonna put that
time we're definitely gonna do the Ford
Taurus here that would be great yeah I
think it'd be a great episode yeah for
these guys we're done so yeah that'd be
awesome
drive Ford or stick show it's funny
because we keep it here and every now
and then we use it for something and it
doesn't start I just had them fix it up
enough so that at least is Street but
literally it has like an old wasp's nest
you should have their bras I'll see you
guys later
you're watching the conan 360 live show
I'm your host Moses storm we're gonna
throw down to Chris at the artists
entrance and a little bit but first off
I just want to let you guys know that
once again this year Funko has made
these like great Conan pop figures
Griffin was nice enough to give us some
tick pop figures but they're doing a
Jedi Conan white Walker Conan basically
just Conan Flash Conan and a mono Conan
that and those were all being given out
to audience members and people go crazy
for those like even when the shows let
out it was just a line of people just
like immediately ready to sell them
online so that's so look for those and
if you ever make it down to one of these
shows well that's what you're getting
you watch Conan on TBS and follow team
Coco on snapchat and Instagram all this
week for a chance to win one of your
very own you can also follow
Christianize at red set it on Twitter
and Instagram and I met Moses storm we
just saw a exclusive behind-the-scenes
look of that West Coast Customs piece
and of course we always want to hear
what you guys think we have a a chat
going at where you guys could chat with
us and we read these these these
comments off it was the huge set piece I
saw them wheeling that backstage and
they were running the engine the entire
time and right now we're gonna throw
down to Chris in the artist entrance
where we're gonna surprise and delight
some fans
some some games as we wait for the cast
of the new lego ninjago movie to arrive
so let's go down to Chris Chris how you
doing down there
what's going on I'm at the artist
insurance right now with all these fans
sitting here waiting on the cast of the
lego movie
Ninjago am i standing right now did mom
know I'm playing and I don't know what
I'm gonna I'm feeling good I'm feeling
gracious you know it's 360 livestream
right now for conan brunch about HCMC
and I got a couple bags here with some
gifts and some tickets to the Conan show
uh who here doesn't have tickets
somebody raise both hands like like one
wasn't enough how about my show who got
sickest you know I think it's and you
can't see them but I might go ahead and
get them this one really sunburned man
right there and he might get some
tickets because he deserves it alright
now I'm gonna play some games Michelle
I'm not gonna give them out you have to
earn these tickets alright first of all
let me show y'all what's in here if you
look in this bag with somebody to show
you you have a Conan towel
yeah in case you just need a bathing
Conan you have you have a coated shirt
bow and you have a mug with some tickets
to the show tonight
that's gonna be owned by somebody who is
gonna play my game two truths and a lie
cover Castile who's ready to do this
Coco come close you played you played it
already one go home sir he's out here
just collecting tickets
alright wait where's the guy where's the
guy with the UH with all the makeup
would you like tickets in the show you
you want us chance to earn them come
here come on right here
make some room for him so he can come
over a little closer make some room for
us we come a little closer you don't
have to see this makeup this makeup is
crazy
can we give me clear a path for this man
right here can't can't can I have him
stand right here with me yo yo look at
him creeped him out real quick get close
get close
he's a demon and I'm just black in
America okay what should what be on the
other side of the barricade
okay now that you've done this they want
you to go back to here because that's
what rules are but but even still play
the game okay now what is your name Jose
Jose where you from Jose San Diego San
Diego how long did it take you to do
this your face three hours three hours
you did it yourself
yeah must've had my sister dead my back
your back your head and that was the
most impressive oh you're just too
silvery I just left your sister huh you
like forget you all right so we're gonna
play two truths and a lie
comic-con style and how this is gonna
work is I'm gonna give you two quotes
from actual superhero movies and I'm
gonna give you one quote from my actual
life and you have to guess which one is
the one for my life you ready okay all
right y'all believe in them that doesn't
sound like you believe it it's not I get
like making noise yeah
do y'all believe in my melee right now
all right here we go man all right a
cat's come when they feel like it not
when they're told
that's a be intelligence is a privilege
and it needs to be used for the great
greater good of people that's B see you
ain't never gonna leave this house until
you learn how to be a real man which one
is not the superhero quote see that's
right that was my dad and it was very
hurtful and now all those those two
quotes cats come when they feel like it
not when they're told and intelligence
is a privilege and needs to be used for
the greater good of people do those do
you know where one of those coats come
from I don't you don't you want to take
a guess on the cats or superheroes who
is a superhero there's a cat Catwoman
that you nailed it somebody nailed it
first within you nailed it eventually
I'm gonna go give you a bag man
there's two tickets to the Conan show
man and you and your sister can go if
she hasn't walked off and anger already
from you leaving her you excited I'm
excited I'm actually gonna give it to my
sister and my brother-in-law you gonna
give it to your sister your brother oh
that's awesome man give it up all day
right now man guys that was awesome
oh I feel I do feel like I'm gonna like
a 90s Missy Elliott video this is crazy
and like soap alright man
who over here is ready to play Oh who's
he was I like everybody else's yelling
and he's the only one like like so
serious about this man what's your name
man named Jordan Jordan Jordan okay
where you from San Jose San Jose I'll
say you see you drove a long way
well we flew but yeah so you didn't
drive at all
no that's dope are you ready to play
this game I'm gonna try my best that's
what we all can export hoes that nuts
not good name that's his name your name
is Jordan call me Jose for the TV no
I'll be anybody you want me to be no
believe in yourself so all right here we
go
here's a with great power comes great
responsibility
here's B it doesn't matter who we are
what matters is our plan and you see a
moment like this won't last forever
you have to seize the moment which one
is not a superhero quote see someone
said B oh you
there's no need you were right yes CC
was said by my mom because she was drunk
yeah okay if you know them do you know
what movie they're from I'll give it to
you again with great power comes great
responsibility and it doesn't matter who
we are what matters is our plan first
one is spider-man and the second one is
Batman Begins oh the second one was bet
the Dark Knight Rises
but it was still Batman yeah okay we
don't have that we don't have to argue
about it I promise you all right but
you'll get a bag yeah here is two
tickets to the Conan show with a bath
towel wait you see so what my wife and I
have been waiting to get in forever so
just two tickets in sight right there's
two tickets or two tickets for you and
your wife I would not joke with you I
would but I'm not joking yeah give it up
for Jorn yo yo that's that's crazy
Jordan just wants something for his wife
which is great
you'll have to sleep on the couch today
and we are having fun we're making
dreams come true
I got one more bag to give out right now
with some tickets one more bag and I'm
gonna choose one person to talk to
we're wise we still waiting on the cast
of the lego movie that's it I said I
said no Django this time they said it's
Ninjago thank you sir
no you can't help now you've already won
[Music]
there's a very high voice for a grown
man I like that a lot
what's your name brother Minesh come on
up come on up a little bit closer don't
you can't I'll get ya yeah yeah okay so
say your name again because yeah I
didn't get the mic in your face man -
man s man that's where you from Orange
County Orange County heard of it heard
of it what what's your favorite thing
about comic-con the people the pictures
all the people just little people
they're here for fun they're there
they're here for the one reason to have
fun that's amazing Minesh they've
brought a tear to my eye man it didn't
really I'm dead inside but I would have
cried I know you ready to play this game
all right all right now hey a dog is a
dog no matter where you see it if it
attacks you better watch out it's a B
just because someone stumbles and loses
their path doesn't mean they can't be
saved and C I shouldn't be alive unless
it was for a reason I know what I have
to do I know what is right which one is
not a real quote hey are you sure no but
you're right I just made that one that
might on my butt
dude you killed it I'm gonna give you
some tickets and you have somebody here
that you can come to show it my wife's
in the show right now your wife's in the
show and left you out here that's gonna
be so fun when you walk over I gotcha
it's amazing all right we're gonna give
you a bag right now man s it is there
somebody else wanna take with you I do
not suggest taking another lady
they're in the show with her - okay how
did this happen to you in Vanessa I drew
the short straw and have too many
friends oh well then you know what man
you seem like a real good guy well you
know hopefully you share but one ticket
with somebody if you would like and you
have a great night all right
thank you uh yeah yeah give it up for
one more time yo all right we're gonna
check back up to most on the roof Moses
what's going on up there man Chris how's
it going it's been an incredible week
here at the Conan show this whole
building is just surrounded by fans and
if in case you've been missing these
shows and you want to catch up on any of
the epic action we have a quick
highlight reel to show you guys
presented by our friends at a TNT let's
check that out
what is it can we eat it
it's skin is so translucent like a sea
jelly
I shall poke it let us all poke it
that was a pokey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go where up Aquaman plus Wolverine the
mash-up is sushi deluxe yeah Aquaman
plus flash flush that would be flush
kitty pryde plus Deadpool that would be
kiddie pool I guess the best way that I
can describe it imagine like like
training day right like the energy of
training day David Rohde training day
right yep yeah pretty good energy of
training day so got it so it's like the
energy of training day meets Lord of the
Rings got it right yeah yeah so like
imagine like Lord of the Rings was like
4,000 years ago yeah but then the
creatures came forward into present day
and now we're in gritty grimy
present-day Los Angeles right but
there's orcs and stuff running over
right even a male who plays Green Arrow
and this is a show this is a show i
watch with this is a show i watch with
my children and so I know this show well
he has said that he would like to do a
crossover on to your show is that
something that Celine it is that
something you would want I'm not sure I
have a show I don't want just random
people crossing over into my show I have
standards I want to prove it's like a
private club I want to lift the rope
let's sum in and then like I'm not sure
you know let the green arrow in flash
I'm not sure you know how is it with you
guys be odd tonight on Law & Order arrow
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the Conan Live
360 pre-show I'm very excited to welcome
my next guest cool up via a sack you
have seen her on the office Parks and
Rec Children's Hospital you've heard her
on Bob's burger and she's also the
creator and showrunner of a very funny
show on see so called bajillion dollar
properties welcome thank you all those
things you said we're correct yeah and I
thank you for honoring me and in such a
beautiful way it's it's very important
for me to and to just go through
someone's IMDB uh but I might yeah I
think I might but I think when you were
clicking on my IMDB page I think you did
it with love yeah and I can feel it
comes through it comes through that
Starr meters up one click yeah thank you
Firefox reload page you just kept
reloading it people enjoy talking about
Starr meters out there absolutely it's
not inside baseball at all anyone
watching a live pre-show at any of the
nursing homes that this is streaming to
or
multiple tabs that people have open they
love star meter jacks before we probably
like get into your show cool up and I
have a past and it's not that's not a
bad thing mm-hmm but you actually hired
me as an intern at UCB The Upright
Citizens Brigade theater and Los Angeles
oh you're still saying that full thing
we've cut it down I'm sorry I'm not as
young as you are 19 okay I'm trying to
get that myth out there that I'm 19 I
even though large flakes of my skin peel
off mid interview okay well I would
recommend a Korean 10-step beauty
regimen and we can talk about it now or
we could do it later I would really love
to get into the 10 steps of Korean
beauty with step no.1 I use I do use
tens up clean I have you do have this
incredible skin thank you you do look
great so whatever it is that I'm sure is
I think I don't know homeopathic no no
there's chemicals there's extreme
there's a chemical bath
you dip yourself in every night like a
West world style whoa madam bath redid
the blood of virgins and I have 10
chemicals that I I dip myself look like
a fun dip but for okay you know an older
woman yeah
and how long does this this whole
process take guys it's not as long as
you think it is okay it's not like
you're really jamming in each step okay
it's it's probably just like five to
seven minutes and you don't do all of
the steps all of the time we could be
doing it during the show absolutes bring
out that table of goop a bunch of goop
yeah but thank you for hiring me that's
that's how it kind of got into UCB if
you're an intern they let you exchange
manual labor for improv classes yes in
some scenes can feel like manual labor
as long as you've got very clear space
work yes yes it o is an interview want
to get hired as an intern even on the
Conan show really should do space work
oh really yeah yeah you really have to
grab the handle and not it's not a ghost
handle you gotta grab that grip lock it
grip feel it feel the weight of it
you're gonna be so proud of me look I'll
smooth this transition is speaking of
improv you do a lot of improv on your
show on seeso bajillion dollar
properties that's right it's a semi
improvised show and you have really
talented improvisers on there yes mr.
Paul F Tompkins yes Ryan Gaul tani
Newsome drew harbour Danna Deut Who am I
missing
Tim bolts from Chicago
oh so what's that like putting together
an improvised show it's a little more
challenging than people think like I
just make it up it's I love this
character core bill Dooley as Amit you
have to be funny and you do have to know
the rule this is bro who watches Curb
Your Enthusiasm this guy is screaming in
woman's opens mouth on campus and then
he goes home god watch that new curb but
he's like he's on like only season 3 but
to him it's new I see yeah that's so
detailed that's how I know it so well so
what is that
like putting together improvised show
because I imagine it would you know it's
fun and loose but it also is a lot to
keep on top of yeah I mean we we have we
have like really detailed outlines with
kind of beats that we that we everyone
knows everyone knows who they are who
they are to each other what they want in
the scene and then those beats are kind
of just like signposts and people can go
off them
we have dialogue if you want it but all
of that means and that there's room for
people to just play and have a good time
because we know where we're trying to go
but you don't have to make up like plot
right that's all on you so we could just
say funny things and okay that was a
90-minute monologue we'll try to push
that into a story on the show Moses
we're not doing 90-minute - no one's
doing soliloquies no one's doing that
you get the studio for maybe like 40
minutes of the soundstage you could
shoot real quick we have three cameras
we do do like eleven minute long takes
and it's on me in post-production to
kind of make it all come together like
it's a reality show yeah how is that
that editing process because it's wrong
but it's long but it's good it is you
can kind of rewrite in editing it really
is like a reality show I do so much
story editing because none of our our
stories I don't plan what episodes
they're going to be in I just decide and
put them together in post-production
that's great and you guys have such
great guest stars on this show it's
Sarah Silverman Zach Galifianakis Jim
rash Tom Lennon Ben garage got Aukerman
the list goes on and on and you make an
appearance right I play a very busty
character very busty lady she's very
muscular in the front and I play a
photographer's assistant - Jason
Mantzoukas min Suk's
sick that's all
million-dollar properties again that's
uncie so when I thank you very much to
my guest
kulap Thank You Moses put me here and
we're gonna go down to Chris
yes you have me in the lobby with some
fans here right now if you guys just
tuning in this is Chris red the other
house that's not on the roof and we're
gonna play some games right now and give
away surprises presented by ATT so we're
gonna start right now uh who wants to go
first just raise a hand quick boom come
on come on brother
come on come on walk around here you
guys this man going first so you can
guys see how this works
don't be nervous nothing's gonna happen
to you that's not gonna be fun
what's your name man he's right he's
dead that's a man he's been he said it
in a very sexy way uh is that way from
Mexico Mexico heard of it heard of it
what brought you out do you live in
Mexico now yes you came up here for
comic-con just for Conan just for Conan
yes oh yeah man that's dope so what's
your feel for me
no for real cheap Oh you lyin person now
what's your favorite part about
comic-con oh go Conan Conan show yeah I
mean I promise to known that from your
last answer all right what we're gonna
do we're gonna play build a better
superhero okay now I'm gonna give you a
superhero that does not exist and then
you're gonna have to in 30 seconds dress
yourself up on like what that superhero
looks like and give me your superpower
and your origin story and if I'm
satisfied and impressed you'll get a bag
of goodies presented by AT&T that sound
good yeah sounds great all right man
I'm gonna give you no no I'll give me a
superhero
Oh armadillo man you ready go you got 30
seconds I'm not counting at all not good
with numbers just go sit in and wait all
right you better hurry up
okay he's making some quick decisions
all right he adds the chef's hat it's
pretty solid with the Jason hockey mask
Oh on top of that fresh he's a hat man
this man is a hat man okay oh and I was
grabbing the Cape takes the hat off boom
he drops the Hat the Hat is going on I'm
narrating everything you seeing it's
happening people are screaming in
another room this is what it's like to
live next to a bunch of college kids all
right
and five four three two one you're done
oh man last grab and now we present to
you done to the done armadillo man it
looks hella crazy okay
I'm a Dilla man what is your superpower
I can I can go to Mexico and San Diego
in just 30 seconds he can travel to
Mexico in other places in 30 seconds
that's great so you basically just have
a passport and go really fast yes and
what is your origin story how did you
become armadillo man well I was homeless
in Mexico and I work as a taco maker and
then just got deported to back to San
Diego
what a terrible origin story well I feel
very bad and that was a very topical
horse or so I'm gonna go ahead and give
you a bag a goodies right now presented
by AT&T man I'm a Dilla man you did your
thing you enjoy that baggie and put all
that stuff back do not take that lasso
which thank you for playing so much we
are here right now manse Chris read down
here one of two hosts for the 360
livestream presented by AT&T for the
pre-show a conan we have our next guest
i'm gonna just pick you come on around
here come on around here lady well I
have my fun like your outfit is that
Mario all these that is so cool what's
your name Emily Emily all right amber
the way from
the Bay Area all right very is this a
dance they touch I do this is the dance
shall do okay we killing it and I what's
your favorite part about comic-con
exclusive dressing up and seeing stars
yeah who's a favorite star it's not
that's not a fair answer kiss a
everybody yeah there you go that's
awesome yeah Chris Pratt is a dope all
right so you know how this game works
right build a better superhero we'll
give you a name of a superhero you have
30 seconds to dress yourself up in any
of these props that we have right here
and then you have to give me your
superpower and your origin story all
right I'll give you 30 seconds now I'm
not counting but I am trusting my gut
are you ready okay
the superhero your superhero is day
which day which go oh
dundun dundun dundun this is music for
her to see the get nervous that she
thinks real facile huffy uh-huh bow bow
bow bow bow bow high-five me bow all
right you got ten seconds something you
got nine seconds I'm sure you got eight
seconds maybe it's bow seconds I can't
count three seconds two we now present
to you they don't do it they wish this
is amazing you did a lot with a little
bit of time you work up wait you see so
what I'm a cosplayer oh she's a
cosplayer this is what she does
okay day which what is your superpower I
can control your mind by just brewing
some magic you can control the mind
which is a little bit of brewing magic
some spells
wow that's already way better than the
last guy okay and what is your origin
story I was playing too many video games
and I got sucked into a TV and then I
just became the superhero yeah you're
like really good at this game
yeah like I want to see this movie of
day which yes
a little bit of trying a little bit
everything in there well you know what
I'm mad impressed already oh I was
impressed you showed up so we're gonna
go ahead and give you this goodie bag
presented by AT&T thank you so much for
playing we appreciate you we got we got
time okay
oh and now we're gonna cut back okay
this is really exciting I'm getting word
right now that the cast of the new lego
ninjago movie are arriving at our
theater so we're gonna go into the
artist cam that's in the alley
right now we have Olivia Munn signing
some autographs with some fans and she's
heading inside right old she stop it for
more fans got a bunch of fans lined up
they've been lined up all day we got
guests arriving and speaking of behind
the scenes little-known fact
Silicon Valley's Thomas Middleditch
actually auditioned for the role of
Dumbledore and I think we have an
exclusive look at his audition for
Dumbledore so let's take a look at that
name please Thomas Middleditch
flatfoots ham and some change okay all
right
did you want to try it in the costume
sure yeah okay it does not do too it
does not do to dwell
it does not do it does not do this guy
doesn't make any sense
speaks in riddles okay this is just
original dialogue of this from them this
is the original dialogue
yeah the official script isn't out yet
so we're just using official Dumbledore
from what book I think it's from all
seven of the Harry Potter books
what okay I don't know this from a
series of fantasy books but a young
magician very common literally seven
Lord of the Rings no it's it's Harry
Potter okay Kendall probably should be
handle I'll do it as Gandalf oh it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
leave have it who shall not pass Gandalf
all right it's as Dana's like you shall
not pass
you shall not pass eighth grade Hobbit
so I'm kind of doing a home now great
yeah to the well-organized mind death is
but the next great adventure
Hobart okay it is from Harry Potter not
the Lord of the Ring got it
so there's no hobbits in their heart
they're aren't sure it's fantasy
you're sure it's dancing you're not sure
I got a beard on a beard and I have my
own beard can deduce I mean you're
supposed to be you it's supposed to be
team you actually got a whole I got a
whole thing
so the well-organized mine death is
about the next great adventure whatever
okay we got that okay yeah that works
there oh hey happiness can be found even
the darkness of times if one only
remembers to turn on the light anyone
needs me
come on just try it at envy where you
different radius thing where you just
gonna cycle in exactly like just gonna
have effective yeah
so does any good yeah that's here that's
good I took a leap it's great we got a
lot okay great good did you have enough
absolutely when you do anything again no
I think we're good okay cool
Thanks thank you see ii didn't know
amazing yeah it's pretty easy for me
actually a lot of people say acting is
higher not not it's great like the whole
thing is easy to get here just you know
ways
cool I think we got it okay great Conan
Live 360 pre-show Wow originally they
were like we can make that one word I
was like no more words yes presented by
AT&T right now we are here with two of
the stars from the very funny show on
TBS called people of Earth please
welcome our two guests Ken haul in be
shored Gustafson welcome to the show
guys
thank you very much who are here we're
just doing a little pre-interview why
Thomas middle interests things are
playing just talking about potatoes and
that's really all you guys are here to
plug potatoes I kind of feel like they
plugged themselves really you know
they're so so delicious morning you know
lunch and dinner I learned something
it was quiet it was quite an
infotainment moment yes before we okay
so we've told that everyone has been
logging off and no one is like preparing
some potato pancakes later on I know a
lot about potatoes and me most know a
lot about people's birth but for the
people who don't
what the hell's our show the show itself
is a wonderful comedy from TBS
hi Greg Daniels Conan O'Brien amazing
people amazing cast yeah so it's about
an alien abductee support group and
Wyatt Cenac is a reporters trying to get
to the bottom
feels that he's had an alien experience
which we play the aliens you guys yeah
this is like a lot of makeup right for
you specifics yeah for myself about two
hours every day you go to two hours yeah
putting it on and off
yeah it's about twenty minutes getting
it off okay what about a good salty some
days we just have one one line one sound
for you you have like the white long
hair yeah I got five hours right there
oh that was an early morning and I'm
looking at Ken I'm like oh I mean for I
mean no I realize it's been here for two
hours before me like picked up 4 a.m. oh
yeah he takes less time to get ready you
know I'm a patient man so I kind of like
the time to self-reflect in the chair
like in touch with myself you know
reflecting on life and inside so it's
overtime all the time like I have to go
to the bathroom I don't I do it all the
time sometimes I sit on the urinal line
people waiting and people drink pretty
heavily there it seems like they got it
under control
yeah yeah I mean compared to this I met
so I I moved to LA like three years ago
yeah and I started dating a girl and she
was like we were out we went out and we
talked met her friends and she was like
uh I mean the I'll sorry he was wasted
he was but like no he was he that's not
wasted like you haven't seen you haven't
seen wasted what is Swedish wasted
Swedish wasted is when you I've seen
people laying down on the grass you know
digging their fingertips into the grass
because they have to hold on to
something while they're laying down has
gravity yeah because the rotation of the
earth is making him nauseous
to my ass yeah my friend came out out of
a bathroom and yes like he he comes out
yes he throwed up all of his shirt like
he comes out we'd puke all over him it's
like all right guys who who did this
drafting their their email to read out
loud to him and their intervention and
he's like and he honestly feels like
someone else you know mine that is
ruined
you know too good to follow this one
again one of my friends is like he's
cross-eyed but when he's when he's
drinking if he look straight at you he's
like that's when you know that's when
he's super dry but you know what what an
honor what did I don't have an alien
swear on our show so you know it's a
huge problem when his eyes are straight
that's like oh he needs to go to the
hospital usually they're not and when if
you look straight at you he's as drunk
as you can possibly get like that is the
did I swear
go through all the swear words and say
them out loud and then see which one oh
I definitely asked you kid because I
know you're a trained clown and you
worked at circus too late how much does
that inform your performance on the show
yeah it's well it's like doing math work
right because I can't really express
fully but through like my my movements
and such and and it's almost like less
is more in a lot of ways and so yeah
it's it's kind of a cool challenge to to
be mindful that okay there's camera and
such because it's hard to hear and being
able to again like kind of like express
what you know Jeff is is feeling in that
moment so any other thing to within the
clown is like
I love playing and so that idea like
playing little moments in such and like
finding the fun with an ad so that
that's I think where my clam comes in
here you know again these are our guests
people of Earth on TBS yes Ken he'll be
shorn yeah these are like baby usually
he's on be on very close to it again
just watch your cheating and marathon
that was well worth five dollars I just
gave you
super super funny yeah brilliant Moses
yeah yeah he watched nothing I did no I
did again that was hilarious
thank you guys so much for joining us on
the conan 360 live show we're about to
cut it right now to Conan and thank you
guys so much for watching have a great
night baby
[Music]